c'est le printemps
ce n'est pas les vacances
la cour du collège devrait être plein de
vie mais cette année pas d'éclats de
voix
pas de jeu
aucun ballon ne fait vibrer les filets
le collège est fermé
l'épidémie de covin assigne les élèves à
résidence
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour voix oui oui ça va merci
bon ça se passera complètement pas très
bien pour le moment
tu viens chez moi avec ma famille le
collège nous manque un petit peu les
professeurs les élèves etc
mais bon pour le moment c'est pas
obligatoire mais j'ai tellement envie de
les voir c'est pas encore comme ça pour
le moment
[Musique]
j'avoue que je prépare à retourner à
l'école plutôt que de travailler à la
maison et chico toute la journée tu
travailles dans un ordinateur lancre je
pense qu'elle va tenir qu'à la fin du
confinement
quand même rester chez soi à pouvoir
profiter son peuple et en arrive à une
période et le soleil revient débat c'est
un peu agaçant
je me dis c'est un peu des vacances mais
pas du tout parce que l'on peut pas
aller chez les grands parents on ne peut
pas aller chez les oncles et tantes
je trouve un peu le temps long je trouve
que des fois les parents c'est un peu
encombrant c'est plus derrière ton dos
qu'un prof
enfin un profil va pas te demander si tu
as rangé tes chaussettes
comment ça se passe le confinement le
français ça va les maths c'est facile je
me débrouille tout seul
d'accord concernant jeu car comme ça tu
penses ouais en fait que les exercices
et tout ça j'aime bien les faire c'est
juste
ben c'est juste en fait l'organisation
bien et vous confirme en europe oui bah
je m'inquiète aussi un peu pour mes
grands parents
et alors qu'à ce temps fort de cette
histoire d'épidémie transit
le président des usa y ait un peu
n'importe quoi s'injecter du gel hydro
alcoolique ou d'eau de javel dans le
porte c'est n'importe quoi
même mon petit frère il voudrait pas
cette idée a les honneurs qu'on empêche
enfin bizarre de voir toulouse est qu'un
masque lancé par la france dans l'écran
va organiser quelques chansons bon
coatch au score on aura tous d'immenses
[Musique]
une décennie c'est le temps que nous
allons passer avec eux il s'appelle maël
colline yasmina ghiwane lilou et mohamed
6 enfants âgé de 11 ans élève dans la
classe de 6e c du collège des gayeulles
à rennes
ces dix prochaines années nous allons
les voir vivre et grandir
quel avenir attend cette génération née
en 2008
que deviendront-ils
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée
la deuxième rentrée de l'année celle du
retour du confinement
ça fait deux mois que les 6e c attendait
ce moment dans les toilettes
drôle d'ambiance
il y a le masque la distance d'un mètre
le lavage de mains à chaque retour de
récré
[Musique]
donc la rentrée de la tâche encore
d'accord mais cette place là elle sera
définitive
d'accord c'est à dire que on ne changera
plus de là jusqu'à la fin de l'année
prenez le temps qu'il vous faut vous
choisissez votre place et après on fixe
les choses d'accord mais tu peux rentrer
[Musique]
une fois en classe
interdiction de s'asseoir côte à côte
bavardage compliqué donc paraître très
différent de ce que vous connaissez du
collège se battre il va falloir qu'on
s'y habitue tous les shows dessous ça va
être particulier des corps est ce qu'il
y à des questions par rapport à ça
s'arrête le premier jour hyper coincé
c'est la première fois pour nous qu'on
arrive dans une école avec des mac du
gel hydroalcoolique toujours se laver
les mains en allant à la récréation pas
pouvoir toucher ses copains et tous ses
patronymes et non alors on va parler de
ce confinement
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti moi
même fait tamponner de la colère est
intéressant ça ah oui quand je savais
que ça allait être compliqué d'apprendre
et ô toi tu avais peur déjà deux par
rapport à ta scolarité étaient en colère
par rapport à ça d'accord qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus marqué les mémoires
cours les cours les bousculades dans les
pouvoirs une sorte cours on va dans un
9e bolidage et les potes et voit la vie
normale au lit depuis pouvoir plonger
dans l'eau ça à sa maman qui trop cher
c'est mais je sais vous vous êtes
entraînés dans la mémoire elle est
passée en avait pas assez grande je
fasse at à côté moi ça m'a manqué par la
vie des gens
quand on allait au collège on se faisait
encore des câlins on se dit saluant son
échec et tout s'est arrêté
on va plus personne donc ça fait bizarre
premier exercice pour les élèves notez
ce que représente le coc vite pour eux
sur le cahier de ghiwane un mot quatre
lettres morts
[Musique]
non
barré à la récré il faut inventer des
jeux covit compatibles
j'ai jamais vos est là quand on arrive
au printemps l'été commence à perturber
au petit l'allemagne qu'est ce qui a
forcé les finales mondiales en eau
salubre aux minières
[Musique]
à la cantine les règles sont encore plus
pointue
[Musique]
non non
mais c'est le seul moment où on peut
enlever le masque
[Musique]
la deuxième rentrée yasmina n'ya pas
encore droit
ses parents ont choisi qu'elle reste à
la maison
à 5 dans l'appartement de trois pièces
[Musique]
avec le petit frère de deux ans qui est
disons aller plein de vie ce n'est pas
si simple à mes parents ils avaient peur
que jettera pleuvait russie voulait pas
j'étais triste et du combat moi je le
souhaite et un petit peu mises de côté
j'ai pleuré parce que j'avais préparé
toutes mes affaires et ça j'ai cru que
j'allais repartir
ils m'ont dit non tu repars pas dit si
je repars et après ben j'étais parti
chez yasmina le confinement a laissé
quelques traces
c'était vraiment le pire moment de ma
vie parce que y avait rien à faire
je m'ennuyais tout le temps j'étais
obligé de faire le ménage
du coup bah je lisais tout le temps et
bah maintenant j'ai l'habitude du coup
je le fais tout le temps
après je voulais 3d quand film enfin
pour aller voir un ami et ça
connu un petit gâteau
[Musique]
merci
sortie colle le mieux pour toi en
confinement qu'est ce que tu aurais aimé
avoir
bah allez à dubaï ou à miami dans une
villa de luxe dans une piscine et ses
taux ouais bah juste une maison avec un
jardin est ce qu'il fait ou est ce qui
fait rêver à la basse et grands après tu
peux aller baigner enfin quand tu veux
quand on a envié et ait de la place pour
bouger enfin pour faire ce que tu y mets
[Musique]
meyer
oui
lille ou non plus n'est pas retourné au
collège dans sa maison en campagne
rennaise avec sa soeur et sa mère elles
ont un rituel elle mange devant une
série la vie à trois lui va bien le
continent il n'y a pas trop de soucis
donc où les élèves les profs ça me
manque un peu
je rêve d'y retourner je ne rêve pas de
tourner mais je suis en mode oui je
mendie retourner qu'on soit possible
pendant leur jeu j'y retournerais et à
d'y retourner
je rêve pas d'y retourner
les loups est bonne élève alors sa mère
préfère qu'elle laisse sa place au
collège à un autre élève qui en aurait
plus besoin
et les journées peuvent être longues
[Musique]
très longue
c'est son père que les loups appelle à
la rescousse alors
ou juste deux semaines tu pense qu'on
peut faire un jeu en ligne
si tu veux on vend d'après midi comme tu
veux tu m'appelles dans tes frères
d'accord quoi vision les parents de
lille où sont séparés elle voit peu son
père ibos aujourd'hui facile mais avec
l'épidémie ils ont trouvé un moyen de
passer du temps ensemble
luna une bonne journée où j'ai fait mes
devoirs alors aidé encore pour longtemps
de la partie même si bien défini et ben
après on descendait au bar ou dans le
jardin
je pense que dit vous c'est beaucoup
plus rapprochée de son papa ils ont
plein de points communs
c'est très bien et peut-être qu'il lui a
manqué ces dernières années je ne sais
pas là jamais exprimé comme ça en tout
cas c'est l'adolescence elle s'éloigne
de sa maman ça ne m'inquiète pas non
plus et pour moi c'est dans l'ordre des
choses
les branches et un gratin de courgettes
avec du poulet banni c'est bien comme ça
qu'on a pris 3,3 du tour alors chaque
c'est toi lil'hoc de gagner la troisième
manche la traîne pendant que yasmina et
les loups sont encore chez elle en cours
d'anglais
les élèves jouent aux petits bacs et new
data east bay mal même bébert get back
in salah
fin de la première journée de cette
deuxième rentrée les sujets importants
peuvent enfin être abordée entre les
deux pays tout scellé cette différence
en fait c'est parce que dans les
pétitions ya dix ans alors d'aller gp
qui tous et on n'a pas trop non
fortnight ouais on est d'accord centre
night est un jeu genre pas du tout
réaliste
ouais tu te fais signer repos tu te tais
les portes ouais tu vois tout de suite
que c'est un monde imaginaire que c'est
faux et two way
pourquoi tu as un jeu peguy c'est sûr
les portes est là je ne signerai pas
trop quoi dire là c'est différent non
dans fortnight déjà d'une curée après
pâques en solo oui je sais mais non mais
je dis pas qu'ils réparent et sur le
marché dicterait apparaît dans le lobby
d'un ton est nu voilà comme ça
a+ après bientôt salut
[Musique]
oh
c'est la nouvelle saison cherry one
c'est la manette qui parle
[Musique]
et barques
tu as vu ya des morceaux de ville sous
contrôle parental scan toi dépêche-toi
pays relève m j'ai coupé
mais c'est vrai un je suis paraît un
petit peu
violent comme ça donc on vient demander
mais c'est quoi les bonnes âmes qui se
tapent dessus dire ou contrôler des zoos
g
c'est pas pour de vrai voilà donc on a
dit d'accord il a déjà dissociés le le
virtuel du du réel donc ce qui nous a
déçus parce que je veux c'est jouer à
jeu ohlala yoann est stressé par l'enjeu
ça fait deux rêves qui joue pas et que
ses copains avec les îles où c'est un
peu un peu ric-rac quant au travail et à
son bail hartock m'a laissé qu'une bâche
et c'est mon jeu je te rappelle que ses
talons c'est interdit au sol on a quand
même grille et une choses là sont dites
ordinateur portable en fait on regarde
l'historique à 23 heures regardez de
youtube fortnight jeudi coûte
faut arrêter ça la maison secondaire
c'est un reste les jeux vidéo pendant le
confinement et même après sont devenus
un bon passe-t-on même sur téléphone il
y a aussi les jeux sans écran
je vais faire comme moi je crois en son
si si ça existe d'autres font leurs
courses ambulants et rouge elles sont
trop belles en blanc et jaune aussi si
avant elle était démodé mais maintenant
ça
mais je pense que du côté de chez du
loup on cherche plutôt à aiguiser son
oeil cinématographique
rien que ça jamais en fait sans regarder
des films mais juste enfin analyser des
scènes analyse personnages leur
expression du fonds ainsi aussi s'il ya
des faux raccords gens trouvent
seulement jamais
[Musique]
maël préfèrent exercer son doigté d'un
nouveau morceau on n'y arrive pas encore
à le faire pg saigne refaire des anciens
morceaux soit j'aime bien tu l'as y
arrive bien mais après je trouve pas cet
accord il y a encore du travail
mais avec un père connaisseurs ça va
mieux et après oui mais je sais trop
[Musique]
chez coline l'ambiance est studieuse
m
ce matin avec sa mère ingénieur c'est lé
travail pour tout le monde
[Musique]
dès les premiers jours du confinement le
collège a lancé une plateforme en ligne
voici pearltrees c'est là que les profs
donnent leurs devoirs aux élèves à eux
d'aller consulter de faire les devoirs
et de les renvoyer aux professeurs tout
en virtuel symétrique par rapport à la
droite des du de la droite à la
lassitude comprenait pas tu pries pour
moi la page est réellement des pieds
maman c'est déjà arrivé que l'un des
parents n'arrivent pas à trouver la
solution
non je crois pas tu fais directement au
style oh oui
pour d autres géométrie peut-être que tu
peux prendre un crayon un porte- minutes
d'accord
la prise en main de pearltrees a été un
peu compliqué sans les profs en face de
soi
il a fallu apprendre à être autonome et
ça n'a pas été facile au début j'étais
pas du tout organiser quand je
commençais quelque chose qui est arrivé
qu'on y avait un autre truc qui arrive
et je le commence à être du coup je les
sais que j'étais en train de faire et du
coup ça allait pas ce que je me disais
qu'il fallait tout rendre le plus vite
possible
je pense que s'il n'est pas eu mes
parents j'aurais pas je m'en serais pas
sorti schultz
en fait je pense que ce qui l'a stressé
au début c'est d'avoir eu l'impression
d'avoir une espèce d'avalanche de
consignes parce que beaucoup de choses
arriver en même temps elle voyait encore
d'autres consignes arrivé alors qu'elle
n'avait pas écluser ce qui était fait au
début et voit ya eu une une semaine ça a
été un peu laborieux quoi il ya eu 1
mercredi où on lui a dit non mais là
c'est mercredi après midi tu travailles
pas tu arrêtes chez coline pas question
pour les parents de laisser les enfants
sans rien faire l'objectif principal
c'est quand même que ça se passe bien
pour les enfants
moi je leur avais dit dès le début c'est
le truc qu'on a pas enfin qu'on a pas
envie d'entendre c'est je m'ennuie chez
la coiffe car on a fait en sorte qu'il
nous aide un peu plus par exemple pour
la préparation des repas
d'une part parce qu'on avait le temps et
puis aussi parce qu'on avait envie qu'il
y participe et qu'ils se rendent compte
de ce qu'il avait à faire on les inciter
à faire un peu de dactylo pour être plus
à l'aise pour taper sur un sur un
clavier à faire un peu d'anglais sur sur
des sites et petits exercices de
vocabulaire il ya des choses bien faites
sur ses récents siècle
le confinement avec un jardin ce n'est
pas la même chose
[Musique]
maintenant que le confinement est
terminé il y a seulement deux jours de
cours par semaine donc le reste du temps
pour mohamed
le télétravail continue doit essayer
d'effectuer primo un diagramme
circulaire et un autre diagramme anbar
spectre ont montré que les chenilles et
parfois il n'y a pas grand chose à se
mettre sous la dent ma part tout un truc
à faire
aujourd'hui la bad et mad pour l'instant
là je suis en train de chercher pour les
autres matières passé à la chasse aux
travaux c'est pas facile aux toitures et
qu elle travaille papa vous pouvez juste
un seul petit travail trip à moi elle
mènerait apprécié le quiz en italien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ils maîtrisent l'outil mais
au début devant l'ordinateur familial
il a vécu quelques moments de solitude
par exemple qu'ils savaient pas où tu
les trouves et le travail du coup des
fois tu avais des retards tu pour rendre
le travail que ça fait pas non plus
comment faire du coup certains profs ne
savais pas que tu avais déjà fait le
travail et il ya plein de trucs comme ça
l'organisation le stress surtout de
parce qu'il nous envoie plein de travail
plein de travaux comme ça et au final on
sait même pas pourquoi commencer ni par
quoi finir je pense que j'ai plutôt
réussi à faire tout mon travail comme si
ça n'a pas été très facile
ce recul est allé manger
[Musique]
mme merkel va faire ça comme ça suite
voilà
[Musique]
la mère de mohammed a repris le travail
en présentiel
alors il retrouve ses habitudes de
garçons autonomie votre manger tout seul
ça me dérange pas trop
[Musique]
blanc
là chaque fois qu'on finit de manger
manar me dit toujours pas mettre au lit
pas nettoyés à table
fashion des bruits je suis tout seul à
la maison
bonjour bon support vesa déjà nombreux
tickets des comptables parce que c'est
un week-end bah oui la mère de mohamed
garde un oeil sur ses devoirs français
maths et j'ai fait de détails on les a
pas de devoir bas à marseille j'ai rien
trouvé a rien trouvé non et sur wii les
mâles déjà ce que tu as fait et on voit
là en maths
ensuite en italien avec des difficultés
ou pas non on peut en français mais ça
allait si je le faire rapidement pour
montrer ce qu'est ce que c'est je
vérifie de temps en temps que des fois
je lui laisse travailler mais je me
rends compte que si je vérifie pas il ya
des choses qui peut échapper il y avait
des devoirs à rendre des fois juge et et
des coups d'oeil pour voir si tout est
ok quoi ou 8 correct 2 incorrect mon
record c'est 10 correct et 0,1 corrects
il ya des matières où c'était un peu
compliqué un bain a écrit avec les pros
fouilles sont au courant tout ça
mohamed ouahmed il est revenu bon pas
très à l'aise j'ai pas eu beaucoup de
retours j'ai clairement il travaille
chaque fois nulle passé aussi
directement du talent je pense que mon
avec ce qu'il faut à 86 à la rentrée
c'est la méthode et les suivants comme
il n'est pas à l'aise avec la
méthodologie du coup quand on lui en
parle
il a encore plus mal à l'aise et espère
c'est ça en fait un bond de travail et
centre mais non ça ne peut que l'aider à
grandir censure
[Musique]
ah oui madame
il est
aujourd'hui au collège c'est un grand
jour les loups est de retour
[Musique]
tout comme yasmina
j'étais trop contente parce qu'on va
j'ai vu tire toutes mes profs les amours
mes amis
la cour de récré j'étais vraiment
content oui les parents ont décidé de
les renvoyer au collège sur le médecin
malgré lui comme d'autres élèves
reviennent aussi une nouvelle salle a
été ouverte
ça démarre avec un cours de français le
médecin malgré lui
acte 1 scène un florilège et qu'aristote
a bien raison quand il dit qu'une femme
est pire qu'un démon peste du foncier
qui je vous ferai très les oreilles
traître un seul entrant peur lâche
qu'aucun temps dargaud bénite tripon
marc au voleur à vous en voulez donc pas
atteint voilà un vrai moyen de vous à
pezi là et bien effectivement on voit il
prend un bâton et lui en donne donc là
ça veut dire que le personnage bien doit
prendre un bâton et donné des coups de
bâton sur l'autre personnage il et nous
c'est une élève qui est très attachante
qui est assez assez renfermé c'est à
dire qu'il va pas forcément beaucoup
vers les autres c'est une élève à part
avec un très bon niveau aussi avec un
entourage assez assez riche ça en fait
quelqu'un de voile avec des remarques
très intéressante en cours mais qui est
qui qui enrichissent en fait le court je
crois que c'est il lui donne un bâton et
lui donne un bâton pour qu elle le
frappe mais en fait non c'est lui qui la
fera non il prend un bâton et lui ont
dit
s'appelle des didascalies quelqu'un les
prononce sur scène non elles sont
distillées simplement au jeu yasmina
c'est pareil c'est une élève que je
trouve pour une sixième du coup je
trouve qu'elle a une maturité en fait là
une maturité développer vraiment pareil
une personnalité très attachante fassiez
vous lui bill haas et expansive et ce
qui est assez assez étonnant en fait
c'est qu'elle a pris français en très
peu de temps une élève assez étonnante
en fait dans sa façon de d'agir enfin
d'interagir et dans son niveau de
français qui est super bon quoi il veut
imposer à sa femme sa façon dans la
chose d'accord est ce que martin est
d'abord moi n'est pas d'accord pas
d'accord
ben dis que je veux que tu vas
m'affronter je veux que tu fais ce que
je te dise exactement
yasmina est forte en france est pourtant
arrivée du maroc en ce1
ça fait peu de temps qu'elle pratique
début 2018 bah je vais pas parler
français et après bah j'ai appris à
parler français
j'ai mis un an à prendre vu que j'étais
nouvelle à l'école et avait vraiment
plein de gens qui venaient me voir qui
vous allez me dire ou es ce que tu veux
qu'on soit mais tout ça est soi disant
ouais enfin bon déjà je comprenais pas
ce qu'il disait je faisais que dire oui
oui oui à tout pour garder le contact
avec les élèves les profs ont lancé un
grand concours en ligne de chorégraphies
dans le langage actuel ça s'appelle un
flashmob
[Musique]
une heure on va réviser le flashmob pour
ceux qui viennent d'arriver cette
semaine un petit effort supplémentaire
pour la maîtriser ce sportif et ça
permet de garder la distance
voici donc le flash mob officielle des
sixièmes
[Musique]
il reste un peu de travail mais ça va
venir
ensuite toujours recommencé à faire
d'idolâtrie interdit dans les p o tac et
la lettre
à
[Musique]
où je vois je
le flashmob ce n'est pas une partie de
plaisir pour tout le monde pas pour maël
en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fin de journée à rennes temps breton
ça m'a touché durant l'hiver voir le
bras mais préfère regarder
[Musique]
ça sert moi parce que j'ai vraiment
l'air qui dans mon boulot
[Musique]
l'arrêté très loin la vérité oui
ce voyage
moi c'est moi petit clin d'oeil au
milieu des livres de leurs parents
professeurs mmes à elle et son frère
sont en pleines joues tu m'aimes à elle
est avant tout un artiste japonais
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui t'a fait restants sont
bien créé et définit ce qu'il faut
savoir sur maëlle c'est qu'il est
exigeant avec lui-même très exigeant et
bryce miller est là au coup une petite
tête
des yeux bizarres et chauffe be there il
a un bras musclés et en me rabats musclé
[Musique]
rarement que j'arrive à me satisfaire
mais en général plus c'est une rattraper
le coup
il faut dire que l'inspiration de maël
est un peu instable se transformer en
acteur que chirac est maintenant je vais
faire une chance de nous les jeunes on
voit comment je vais cogner comme je
sais quoi sert ces chevaliers sport
compliqué tuer quelqu'un avec une armure
une ip un docker de chirkat est
allergique
car gladiateurs cours d'histoire où les
bd astérix
une petite tête jamais en mêlée fermée
il ya bien meilleur que moi
des dessins il en a une sacrée
collection personnages et une seule page
le satisfait soit là mais le reste ça
c'est fait je ne dirais pas du goût de
[Musique]
la lecture venons ici c'est une grande
passion parmi les 6e c
[Musique]
alors
est-ce que les et touche pour les percy
jackson qui a dit que la jeunesse ne
lisais plus on peut dire comme ça c'est
tout c'est du même auteur dans celui-là
on retrouve percy jackson qui y qui
arrive dans un clan romain l'adorent la
lecture avant j'aimais passage préféré
écrire mais maintenant celle inverse est
la grande star
qu'est ce que j'y pense mot prend la
voici en ce moment je lis ça
la baguette de sureau mais où n
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'un transport voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la baguette de cheuvreux la baguette ou
puissants dans harry potter petit
trifide canus total
crash les masses
ridicule ou ce fait devient ridicule en
doloris en gros celui qui le reçoit
c'est comme s'il se faisait torturé
avada kedavra celui qui est touché
himeur direct boom comme ça sans aucune
trace ni rien propre net
bon j'en connais pas mal harry potter
les romans harry potter la baguette
magique
harry potter les produits dérivés et ça
c'est la pierre de résurrection on casse
la pierre parce que c'est un horcruxes
de voldemort
j'aime bien aussi les boeufs par exemple
dans un des harry potter
il utilise en sortilèges pour faire
venir son balai à lui à lui pour pouvoir
va participer à quelque chose j'en dis
pas plus parce que bastille non ça
serait du spoil
[Musique]
m
et dans la cour de récré harry potter
[Musique]
coline lectrices impassible en est à la
fin du cinquième tome c'est le moment où
voldemort va mais n'en disons pas plus
sinon ce sera du spoil c'est fini
[Musique]
retour sur terre les sixièmes c'est
après une mauvaise nouvelle
[Musique]
jeudi prochain ce sera notre dernier
cours de ps ensemble parce que je vais
quitter l'établissement g mutation là
pour une autre académie donc bah vous
aurez il y aura quelqu'un d'autre à ma
place je voulais vous dire que j'ai
passé une merveilleuse année avec vous
j'ai énormément apprécié votre état
d'esprit dans la classe et ça si je peux
me permettre de vous donner un conseil
pour peut-être tout le reste de votre
scolarité
que vous soyez tous ensemble ou dans une
autre classe c'est de garder ça d'accord
c'est une belle qualité humaine que vous
avez marre face à cette épreuve il
décide de réagir
j'ai par des lignes stade et du but
comme ça voilà pourquoi la route a fait
plein de petits chocolats en forme des
forces de
on ne sait pas ce qu'ils font a donné
match que moi tu demandes aux blessés et
tous moi j'ai besoin de quelque chose
mais
[Musique]
grande nouveauté grâce aux qu'ovide le
thé les conseils de classe en voici la
retransmission en multiplex depuis la
chambre d'amis de madame mathieu
[Musique]
commence alors pour rappeler ben c'est
bien justement pour que tout le monde
l'a remarqué je veux dire positivement
[Musique]
l'adaptation a pris confiance
cette classe très positif voilà ce sont
des élèves qui fonctionne très bien
l'ambiance de classe a été extrêmement
positive ce sont des élèves qui ont
montré beaucoup d'entrées d'entre eux
alors il n'y a jamais eu de de moqueries
ils ont toujours pu s'exprimer librement
donc c'était c'était agréable c'est
désormais officiel
nos six élèves sont acceptés en
cinquième soulagement et chanter à
charge de vous approcher
allez dernière ligne droite avant les
grandes vacances sans réserve
vous gardez plus d'un mètre de distance
[Musique]
marché
et
[Musique]
arrive le dernier jour de cours avec
madame mathieu c'est le moment de lui
offrait un bel adieu la désole ici la
mariée n'est pas très l'a dit je répondu
c'est beaucoup c'est la lettre pourront
vous écris dément néanmoins même des
cadeaux leur permet beaucoup fait c'est
beaucoup trop ce qu'ils aient trois
deramaix du chocolat encore j'ai une
tête à manger du jour où l'asie madame
jamais une carte qui a fait le point sur
sa vie en rose
j'ai bien envie de vous faire tout cela
calmement mais j'ai peut pas déjà ça se
fait pas bien alors en raison des fonds
qu en plus maintenant
[Musique]
ma
moi aussi j'aimerais bien vous revoir un
jour je garde est vrai qu'avec loupe
franchement je m'en voilà je fais tous
un gros câlin un gros merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
à cause de l'épidémie le dernier cours
de sport se résume à une simple balade
dans le parc
[Musique]
plein d'émotions
le premier à l'est boston
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça a été une très belle année avec vous
je suis très contente et très fier
d'avoir été votre tour principal et
gardez votre état d'esprit
vraiment voilà votre humanité votre
entraide voilà et puis peut-être que la
ville fera t'on se recroisera et merci
encore pour voilà pour retour tout c'est
comme ça je vais y aller
au revoir le film merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup lui change pas je reste elle
que tu es d'accord mais bon peut-être un
peu grandir oui tu grandis un petit tu
veux mais humainement tu resté le même
d'accord lilou bonne continuation à 3 et
les mois mais fait-il en mati feu de
barres de son conseil jova comprennent
pas d'accord ok mais quand on te fait
une remarque si pour qq province
d'accord soit moins exigeants avec toi
même tu as le droit de te tromper
khaimah d'accord maynard 1
elle a fait beaucoup
la fin de l'année quand le collège est
vide c'est le moment où les élèves
attendent fébrilement le bulletin de
notes
yasmina l'a déjà lu elle est assez fier
de le montrer à son père
alors donc l'on nous dit aux français
des efforts ont été faits pour rendre le
travail à distance
après on en mathématiques le des lopins
duel positif hong lei donc ils sont
mignons entre deux rires de la capacité
ou non
en anglais c'est mais c'est magnifique
c'est un bon travail
donc il faut rester sur la même latitude
mais plus loin aïe c'est très
satisfaisant mauvais donc la jeunesse
disait si tu peux faire mieux et c'est
de toujours faire mieux si ça l'a vu la
vie il faut faire une fois il faut aller
de l'avant
tu sais fario gay non non je suis nommé
sais pas c'est pas moi je te conseille
est ce que ce serait pas mal d'avoir 16
17 ou 18 ou 20 ça serait bien aussi
d'avoir 20 c'est pas ça c'est le top
oui récession globale les bases sont
solides et vous pouvez aborder la
rentrée de 5e sereinement
bravo pour ce beau résultat
nous vous félicitons d'un haut pour
votre investissement durant la période
du confinement et c'est l'échec d'un
établissement donc donc c'est très bien
mais tu peux se réduit toujours
cet été avec ses parents elle devait
aller voir sa famille au maroc mais avec
l'épidémie le voyage a été annulé ses
vacances
elles vont se passer à rennes jour en
football
l'année scolaire est terminée mais les
6e c veulent se voir une dernière fois
avant de se quitter pour deux noirs
[Musique]
ils ont donc organisé un pique nique
sans adultes
[Musique]
souvenirs à qui sont légaux blair ouais
je blague le 19 mai cet après midi ils
font ce qu'ils veulent
ça fait des grands on va les tester mais
finalement ça fait un arrêt dans le
temps le fait de changer de place à
chaque fois qu'on change de fou j'étais
un peu bizarre si on pouvait rester la
même classe ce serait bien
[Musique]
un poteau
une autre
pendant que certains essaient de percer
sur tik tok
[Musique]
d'autres jouent au bon vieux jeu
trois vieux colline derrière et puis ça
[Musique]
pêche début
je vais retourner chez mamie elle va
s'inquiéter
c'est basique désolé formatrice au
revoir nous avons trop plaisir de te
revoir
[Musique]
cet été pour mohamed il va y avoir du
changement de préparer les cartons
j'aimerais bien que quelqu'un l'ait pris
peur en place mohamed et sa mère vont
s'installer près du centre-ville quitter
ce logement social ça fait trois ans
qu'ils attendaient ça c'est de la bouche
l'objectif est de sortir de ce quartier
quoi céder ou de feu c'est tout le temps
comme ça moi je vis des fn comme ça où
ils se promènent avec des flingues et
moi ça me fait peur mohamed aussi est
content de partir que c'est un quartier
très lugubre
j'ai l'habitude de m'isoler genre dans
cette maison alors pour moi quand l'on
quand je suis divorcé quand j'arrive
dans cette maison c'est comme si j'étais
dans un autre endroit mois mais dit sors
pas je le protège au fait j'ai
l'expliqua des fois et mehdi ben ammar
mais comment ils sont d'ailleurs tous à
moi tu me laisses jamais sortir mme
amélie granby c'est l'adolescence qui
arrive c'est à dire bah je reste à
l'amener à un moment donné mama ba non
je vais sortir
côté avantages dans le quartier il y a
le centre de vacances où elles
travaillent toutes les semaines alors je
serais pas là toute l'année ça lui
permet de faire des activités et de
rencontrer de nouveaux copains
aujourd'hui dans la bonne humeur il sort
de rennes
et il part à la recherche d'un fruit
qu'il adore en fait vous trouver des
fraises bien ou non soit et on se fit
aux devoirs la télé et tout ou soit tu
viens ici c'est la qualité sinon tu vas
trop ce que ferait égaler trouver une
bonne lagarde ait trouvé une bonne grâce
au centre de loisirs ces vacances sont
bien remplies serre a permis d'aller
dans un parc d'attraction au lasergame
dans un parc aquatique bientôt dans un
camping 4 étoiles et voilà plein de
choses regardons à cette phrase tout
rouge
[Musique]
quand mohamed est à la cueillette
colinet à la ferme pédagogique près de
chez elle
bien fait l'ancien coach electric thermo
demain les enfants
mais le fait de s'occuper des animaux de
la ville à perdre j'ai des copines qui
m'en ont parlé du coup bah j'ai testé
j'ai bien aimé trouver retour colline
est une habituée et les animaux ça ne
lui fait pas peur
le palais stoclet tout soit
elle vient ici trois jours seulement une
simple escale dans son programme de
vacances très chargé au début on allait
dans un gîte avec des copains de papa
maman
après on est allés chez ma grand-mère en
normandie
après on part dans un chalet dans le sud
est après ans remonte pour les dernières
semaines chez mes grands-parents dans
ses noces faire à deux heures de voiture
de rennes sur la côte de granit rose
ghiwane cherche le sens du vent le
grabat langue tu vois le vent il ya
comme ça
d'accord donc c'est le vent de travers
ses grands parents ont une maison ici
alors tous les étés il passe deux
semaines à naviguer et sa physique
ma le bateau il s'est enlisé en marin
expérimenté il a le privilège de
naviguer seul
[Musique]
alors
c'est trop bien conduire un bateau sans
permis bateau fabuleux et un virement
nord ok
pro b c'est la tête
mais tout n'est pas parfait désolé rien
de mieux que l'air marin pour penser à
l'avenir et à la rentrée en cinquième
contre la cia
sauf que balla pas possible
j'espère travailler côte à côte je vais
pas ma voix mais sûrement et maël on a
traîné toute l'année ensemble
[Musique]
pour savoir où le vent mènera les
enfants rendez vous l'année prochaine
oh
ok on a lille où mohamed ghiwane qui
vont être est 5e et aux collines
maëlle et yasmina qui vont être en
cinquième
[Musique]